okay so in just a couple hours by all
accounts President Obama is about to
announce an executive action to change
the way our immigration system works
it sounds like about five million people
who are currently in the country will
become citizens there's gonna be some
other things so I don't want to focus on
the actual battle of immigration but I
think it's really important to talk
about what's going on here and why it's
happening now for all these years for
these last bunch of years where the
Republicans weren't giving President
Obama a bill to sign because they want
certain things in their immigration
package he wants everything in his so
they knew if they give him something he
wasn't going to sign it and he didn't
want to sign something that he didn't
believe in so just nothing happened and
that's just sort of how the government
works now of course Obama didn't do
anything when the Democrats for his
first two years he didn't do anything on
immigration when they controlled both
houses of Congress so I don't why not
exactly we never get a straight answer
on that when they could have been the
Democrats could have done what they
wanted and done it through the proper
channels in the way the government's
supposed to work they didn't anyway
now the Republicans are in control of
both houses and Obama is now going to
take an executive action which means by
passing a branch of the government the
Congressional branch which was supposed
to write the laws right they legislate
then he as the executive is supposed to
sign them into law and the judicial
branch is supposed to make sure that
these things are legal so our government
is not supposed to operate with huge
overhauls in our system just coming by
the stroke of a pen of the president now
of course all the Democrats or I can say
all put a lot of Democrats are just
defending Obama and they want
immigration done so they want to defend
their guy and the Republicans I'm sure
if they had a Republican president in
who wanted to do it his way they
wouldn't be all upset as they are now so
it's posturing on both sides but to me
there's something much bigger going on
here if you're going to have principles
and you're gonna believe in the
Constitution the way the system here is
supposed to work
then it's bigger than this particular
issue so even if the legal mumbo-jumbo
even though Obama who is a harvard law
professor has said many times he's not
the emperor it shouldn't be allowed to
do this in baba bhot now he's gonna do
it if you have principles and you don't
want the next guy to come in and also
skirt the way things are supposed to
work then unfortunately this isn't how
it should go down and
even if it's the right thing even if
it's a principled stand which is up for
debate
anyway I want the system to work better
I think a couple people also are out
there are you let me know